هذا وقالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان 3000
جندي خضعوا للعلاج في قسم الطب النفسي
التابع للجيش منذ بدايه الحرب واضافت ان
اكثر من ال000 جندي اسرائيلي من القوات
النظاميه والاحتياط تلقوا علاجا لاضطرابات
النفسيه واشارت هيئه البث الى ان
75% من الجنود الذين جرت معاينتهم تلقوا
علاجات نفسيه واكدت ان
82% منهم عادوا للقتال في قطاع
غزه تنضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان التطورات
الميدانيه من حيث انت وايضا تداعيات
الحاله النفسيه للجنود على نفسيه الجيش
بشكل عام وكيف يتفاعل هذا الموضوع داخل
اسرائيل نعم مدانيا هذا اليوم تجدد القصف
المدفعي منذ ساعات الصباح على مناطق
متفرقه في شمال قطاع غزه من هذه المناطق
في المناطق الحدوديه في منطقه الغلاف
الشمالي للقطاع نسمع طيله الوقت استهداف
بالقصف المدفعي
لمواقع في تحديدا مناطق بيت لاهيه وبيت
حنون على الاغلب هذا القصف ربما يتوقف في
الايام الاخيره الماضيه احيانا
ويتجدد في احيان اخرى مع انسحاب لاعداد
كبيره من الفرق والوحدات العسكريه التي
كانت تعمل في المناطق الشماليه تحديدا وفي
المناطق المحاذيه
للشاطئ الاحياء الغربيه للقطاع في شمال في
شماله تحديدا ولكن ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
صباح هذا اليوم وفي بيانه الصباحي يتحدث
عن ان هذه الاشتباكات ايضا مت واصله في
المناطق الشماليه وذكر بانه في المنطقه في
شمال القطاع ووسط القطاع خلال الساعات
الار الماضيه دارت اشتباكات في مواقع
مختلفه وبحسب قوله قامت قوات الاحتلال من
وحدات مختلفه بتصفيه عدد من المخربين يقول
ان الحديث يدور عفوا يعني بلغته المسلحين
الفلسطينيين او المقاومين فلسطينيين ويقول
بانه هناك عشرات من المسلحين قتلوا تحديدا
في المناطق الشماليه وفي وسط قطاع غزه
وربما بعد ما حدث في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه التي اعلن فيها عن انسحاب عدد من
الالويه في ال هذه المناطق يعود في
بياناته الصباحيه ليؤكد مجددا بان هناك
اشتباكات ليقول بان القوات الاسرائيليه ما
زالت تعمل في هذه المناطق بعد الجدل الذي
اثير ايض ايضا في داخل اسرائيل عن جدوى
انسحاب الجيش من هذه المناطق في حين ان
القياده السياسيه لم تضع اي خطه واضحه خطه
استراتيجيه للتعامل مع هذه المواقع التي
تم الانسحاب منها من قبل الجيش اسرائيلي
فنرى ان المتحدث العسكري يتطرق تحديدا الى
هذه المناطق ويقول بان القوات ما زالت
هناك وانها تقوم بملاحقه
واستهداف المقاومين ال فلسطينيين وانه يتم
طيله الوقت او تقوم طيله الوقت بالقيام
بما يصفه بمداهمات محدده وفقا لما تستدعيه
ال الاوضاع الامنيه هناك اي انه كلما تم
رصد مسلحين وفقا لبياناته او خلايا كما
يصفها تقوم باستهداف قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بمضادات للدروع او نقل اسلحه
فان الجيش يقوم باستهدافها لكن القتال
الضاري والاشتباكات عنيفه ما زالت تدور
تحديدا في منطقه غرب يونس رغم انه منذ
ايام بدا المحللون العسكريون يتحدثون عن
ان الجيش قد يتم مهامه العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه في غضون ايام قليله لكن يبدو ان
هذا لم يحدث ولا يحدث بعد بسبب المقاومه
الشرسه التي تواجهها قوات الاحتلال في تلك
المناطق اذ انه منذ عده اسابيع يتحدث
الجيش الاسرائيلي في بياناته عن نفس ربما
يم استخدم نفس المصطلحات التي تتعلق بما
يدور في منطقه غرب يونس تحديدا من استهداف
لمقاومين والعثور على انفاق ووسائل قتاليه
ومستودعات للاسلحه تابعه لحركه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حماس من جهه اخرى هناك جدل
ايضا في اسرائيل على قضيه الاعلان من قبل
القاده العسكريين بانهم ينوون بانهم ينوون
تقديم استقالتهم في اي وقت ستنتهي فيه
الحرب وهذا يثير واسعا في داخل اسرائيل
هذه الايام ايضا بعد الكشف عن ذلك فدا
شكرا لك نجوان سمري من غلاف غازه